[Musik]
unsere rufe singen den letzten jahren
lauter geworden
die rufe von uns frauen nach rechten
chancen und respekt bewegungen haben
millionen von uns auf die straße
gebracht und aufgezeigt dass männer und
frauen immer noch ungleich behandelt
werden was die welt braucht sind
sichtbare frauen mächtige frauen sowie
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer die eine
armee von rund 200.000 beschädigt
der größte gender gap den ich in meinem
berufsalltag begegne ist die abwesenheit
von frauen und es ist die tatsache dass
frauen nach wie vor deutlich schlechter
bezahlt sind als die männlichen kollegen
brauchen die yolanda spielregeln die
sich alleine gegen sexismus der
schweizer medienbranche stellt und
gewinnt wenn ich die zeitung lese da
sind frauen noch immer dekoration und
spielen formen der werbung mitunter
stürmisch
und frauen wie die schwedin annika los
die eine der letzten männerdomänen
aufmischt
die pornografie wenn wir über sex reden
dann gibt es auch heute noch einen
großen unterschied zwischen männern und
frauen die so genannte orgasmus kluft
was man online sieht auf den ganzen
gratis pornoseiten ist für männer
gemacht nämlich sehr harte vaginale
penetration ich und die meisten frauen
da draußen wissen dass es für eine frau
viel einfacher ist zum orgasmus zu
kommen wenn wir unsere hand benutzen
durch die totale stimulation diese
frauen spielen die hauptrolle in dieser
serie
weil sie aktiv dazu beitragen dass die
welt zu einem gerechteren ort wert mein
name ist patrizia laeri ich bin ökonomen
und feministin wir frauen haben ein
geldproblem wir verdienen weniger als
männer auf gleichen positionen
ich bin auch mutter und kenne die
belastung die berufstätige frauen mit
kindern aushalten müssen
als journalistin beschäftigt mich dass
wir frauen öffentlich viel weniger
sichtbar sind als männer
zum beispiel auf der größten
wissensplattform der welt wikipedia
klaus traube problem es hat viel mehr
männliche biografie als übliche
biografie auf wikipedia finden sich mehr
pornodarstellerinnen als lyrikerin
hat eine studie 2015 gezeigt warum ist
die pornografie immer noch alle solche
männerdomäne
und was ändert sich wenn frauen
mitmischen hallo mein name ist enke last
und ich bin eine erotik filmemacherin
antworten suchen wir bei der spiegel
erika los sie produziert realistische
pornografie und findet wir brauchen
dringend andere bilder von sexualität
als diejenigen im mainstream pornos
[Musik]
between halten
jetzt geben
mit aus dichten reich
vorschein
[Musik]
erika lust gilt als die weltweit
erfolgreichste produzentin
feministischer pornografie aber keine
pornografie überhaupt feministisch sein
alice schwarzer und viele andere
feministinnen meinen nein
dazu gehört auch die amerikanische anti
porno aktivistin geld 1 das erika lust
ist nicht feministisch sie ist eine
porno produzentin sie nutzt frauen aus
um ihren profit zu maximieren und um mit
ihren körpern geld zu verdienen
die deutsche laura méritt veranstaltet
ein feministisches porno festival und
zieht diese problematik auch über 90 der
pornografischen filme sind sexistisch
rassistisch apple lässt sich die arbeit
von erika last ordnet sie aber anders
ein
erika last hat eine sehr sehr gute
arbeit geleistet weil sie ist wirklich
schafft die leute abzuholen wo sie sehr
ästhetischer art und weise so dass leute
mit kriegen da gibt es einen ganz
schönen ansatz das kann ich mir gut
angucken und auch erika lust selbst ist
der meinung klar ist nicht alles perfekt
in der pornobranche ich würde es gerne
sehen wenn mehr frauen mehr menschen aus
der lgbt chorgemeinschaft und mehr
menschen mit verschiedenen ethnischen
hintergründen in das geschäft einsteigen
würden nicht nur als darstellerinnen
sondern indem sie teil der industrie
werden als produzentinnen vertreibe
rinnen und geschäftsführerinnen
in diesem willen beleuchten wir die
kurzarbeit und gehen einem der ältesten
streitpunkte der feministischen bewegung
auf den grund heri klas lebt und
arbeitet in barcelona hier befindet sich
auch der sitz ihres unternehmens last
productions auf dem weg dahin möchte
rosanna dritter die macherin dieses
films von mir wissen wie viel ich denn
bereits weiß über die porno industrie
als wirtschaftsminister habe ich mich
dem thema pornografie natürlich ganz
anders angenähert bisher
diese multi milliarden umsätze
angeschaute sehen monopolistischen
strukturen macht ballungen nur einer
plattform in der erotikbranche oder
porno industrie und auch diese kreativen
business modelle in der digitalen welt
und abgesehen jetzt von der ökonomischen
seite
das wissen ist es ganz eine neue welt
für mich und mich beschäftigt schon auch
das genau pornografie eben das thema ist
was auch die frauenbewegungen was auch
den feminismus extrem spaltet und
natürlich auch ganz viele menschen haben
ein moralisches problem damit so ein
bisschen aufgeregt auf jeden fall
das hat mich aufgeregt bin ich vor allem
weil ich keine ahnung habe was mich in
einer porno produktionsfirma erwartet
zeigt es herauszufinden
mein erster eindruck bisher entspricht
hier nichts dem image einer
schmuddeligen branche
im gegenteil das productions scheint mir
sehr elegant wenigstens von außen
hallo wir haben es endlich geschafft
willkommen bei last wie geht es dir der
fokus von erika schaffen ist nicht zu
übersehen
die trophäen die sie für ihre filme bei
bisher erhalten hat sprechen eine
eindeutige oder zweideutige sprache hier
drinnen ist mein büro
das ist also das hauptquartier das ist
der las braun warschau diese decke an
du schaust bestimmt ständig nach oben
ich schaue oft nach oben in dieser
wohnung lebte eine aristokratische
familie
sie hatten sogar eine kleine kapelle und
schaue was ich damit gemacht habe
[Musik]
und dann ist es endlich zeit dafür mit
ein paar klischees aufzuräumen
fangen wir an ich werde meine stimme auf
machst du das nicht
wie müssen wir uns einen gewöhnlichen
arbeitstag von dir vorstellen
ein normaler arbeitstag
die leute stellen sich vermutlich vor
dass ich ständig von pornostars umgeben
bin und wie ein limousinen herumfahren
und champagner trinken
mein leben ist so wie das der meisten
arbeitenden frauen
ich verbringe viel zeit am computer
schreiben sie ihre schaue mir
filmmaterial an lese ideen von anderen
und schreibe eigene scripte aber dann
gibt es auch spezielle tage an denen wir
einen film produzieren
diese tage sind sehr intensiv und wir
versuchen dann den bestmöglichen film in
der verfügbaren zeit zu machen
die wo es dir etwas an deshalb müsse
nicht wenn sie ins geschäft kommen
so können wir ihr gespräch auf dem wenn
sie über die hochzeit sprechen
sie suchen einen speziellen sari an
solch speziellen drehtagen dürfen
tv-teams normalerweise nicht dabei sein
bei uns macht erika aber eine ausnahme
mit ihren darstellerinnen geht erika das
drehbuch und instruiert ihr team für die
dreharbeiten später
[Musik]
der porno der heute hier gedreht wird
heißt das sorry shop er basiert lose auf
der erotischen fantasien der kundin
solche verfilmt sie in ihre reihe iks
confessions 211 fantasien sind so
bereits filmische realität geworden
erika was erwartet uns heute was du
heute warten kannst es dass dieser dreh
fast gleich ist wie jeder in lee film
drehen mit dem einzigen unterschied dass
wir sex filmen während wir diese sex
szenen drehen dürfen nur kamerafrau
tontechniker fotografen und kamera
assistenz in unmittelbarer nähe sein
[Musik]
das restliche team steht hinter dem
vorhang
wir stehen also nicht vor den darstellen
denn ich finde wirklich dass sie etwas
freiraum brauchen um diese intimität
miteinander zu haben und einen sicheren
ort zu schaffen
okay gibt es noch weitere regeln wie
soll ich mich verhalten
es gibt natürlich einige regeln
bezüglich der corvette pandemie
ansonsten solltest du allen menschen mit
respekt begegnen ganz normal so meine
lieben ich bin schon zu spät ich sehe
ich spähte ok vielen dank während erika
die sexszenen dreht unterhalte ich mich
mit zwei statistinnen beide haben
indische wurzeln
für sie ist es darum ein fast
revolutionärer akt in einem porno von
erika lust mitzuwirken
wenn auch nur als statistinnen 6 vor der
kamera haben sie keinen
was denkt ihr über die mainstream
pornoindustrie wo ich herkomme ist sex
und liebe ein tabuthema
trotzdem schauen sie sich männer diese
paulus an und erwarten von uns frauen
dass wir uns so verhalten
ein expecting aber indische frauen sind
nicht so wie wurden dazu erzogen sehr
rein zu sein und es hat eine ganz andere
dynamik wenn es von der pornografie
kommt und das finde ich schrecklich
viele jugendliche in indien schauen sich
diese art von pornografie an
und das hat einen negativen effekt es
gibt offensichtlich noch viel zu tun ich
denke erika lust ebnet den weg dass
frauen 6 gegenüber offener sind die
szenen mit monate jung player werden als
nächstes gedreht und auch die
hauptdarstellerin des films ist gerade
in der maske ihr name ist super und auch
für sie sind ihre indischen wurzeln ein
großes thema hallo karin schön dich
kennenzulernen hallo freut mich du bist
co regisseurin und schauspielerin
das ist sehr besonders
[Musik]
ich finde das südasiatische identitäten
besonders kreiere nicht genug
repräsentiert sind
das wollte ich vor der kamera aufzeigen
aber ich wollte auch meine eigene
geschichte erzählen
das war mein eigentliches ziel ich habe
als darstellerin angefangen und dann
realisiert das südasiatische menschen
vor der kamera zu integrieren nicht
genug ist das hat mich dazu angetrieben
meine eigenen filme ideen aufzuschreiben
und darüber zu sprechen
und du fühlst selten mit männern wieso
ich finde dass sie ihre sexualität ein
fluid sind und dass das sechs so schön
und organisch und unkonventionell ist
wenn ich mit sechs männern arbeite ist
die arbeit sehr stereotyp und was wir
seinem handbuch es ist nicht so dass ich
persönlich mit cis männern arbeiten will
es ist nur nicht meine erste wahl denkst
du dass pornografie demnächst ich sagen
kann ja sicher ich finde jede chance den
medien oder kunst kann termin ist ish
sein bevor die szene mit karl amon ali
und crea gedreht wird proben sie lasst
uns mit der probe beginnen
[Musik]
die hochzeit ist in zwei wochen und ich
suche etwas elegantes ich mache zu viele
farben
vielleicht hat das in blau und grüntönen
das ist von anfang
im gegensatz zum mainstream porno sind
bei erika lust die weiblichen
darstellerinnen nicht einfach sechs
objekte sondern selbstbestimmte frauen
die ihre eigene lust ausliegen
[Musik]
und wir wollen das jetzt für dich ich
hab's mir so anders vorgestellt obwohl
uns ja gesagt worden ist es ist anders
als wir es uns vorstellen von lkw
vorgewarnt er aber darüber habe ich mir
das irgendwie ich habe nicht erwartet
dass ich mich für diesen digitalen
hippen startup aus aller welt junge
engagierte leute die witze reißen die
social eisen er wirklich ich glaube wenn
wir wenn wir jetzt mal bei einer
sexszene wirklich dabei gewesen wäre
dann wäre es schon noch mal ein bisschen
anders gewesen wahrscheinlich durften
wir ja auch nicht dabei sein wo haben
sie haben schon gemerkt da kommt dann
schon stress aus aber trotzdem was
gelernt wurde also die accadis dann
schon regie führen
einigen ist es vielleicht schon vorher
aufgefallen
erika lust arbeitet an ihrem drews
beinahe ausschließlich mit kamera frauen
und ton technikerinnen zusammen
ich habe den unterschied zwischen kamera
frauen und männern gesehen wie sie den
fokus unterschiedlich setzen so viele
heterosexuelle männer filmen den
weiblichen körper
denn das finden sie am schönsten
und darum haben wir dann stunden um
stunden an material von weiblichen
körper in solchen fällen fehlen mir dann
aber aufnahmen des männlichen körpers
ich habe versucht dies meinem team zu
erklären damit wir ein ausgewogenes
verhältnis an bildmaterial
mit einigen wenigen männern arbeitet
erika los dann aber doch zusammen allen
voran mit ihrem ehemann pablo ordner mit
ihm hat sie ihre firma vor 17 jahren
gegründet bei einem drink in ihrer
lieblingsbar in barcelona erzählen wir
die beiden wie es dazu kam und wie sie
sich damals kennengelernt haben
[Musik]
wir haben uns im sommer 2000
kennengelernt
ich habe hier in barcelona spanisch
gelernt und als ich eines abends mit
meiner schwester und einem freund
ausgeliehen ist dieser herr aufgetaucht
und sie hat mich angesprochen was mich
noch heute verblüfft normalerweise
passiert das nicht
was hast du gedacht als erika die
erzählte was sie so macht als ich sie
kennengelernt habe war sie noch nicht
die erika lust
sie war einfach eine studentin das war
im jahr 2000 erika hat ihren ersten film
im jahr 2004 gedreht als wir schon vier
jahre zusammen waren
ich war sehr am thema sexualität aus
einer weiblichen perspektive
interessiert
das war das skript welches ich
geschrieben habe der grund war
ich hatte damals einen blog auf dem ich
über sex feminismus filmproduktion und
pornografie geschrieben habe und dort
habe ich dann auch meinen ersten
kurzfilm the good girl veröffentlicht
[Musik]
und in sehr kurzer zeit hatte ich zwei
millionen downloads und leute haben mir
geschrieben
erika wir lieben deinen film er ist
komplett anders als alles was wir bisher
gesehen haben mache so bitte mehr filme
dann machst du mir filme
[Musik]
und das war der moment in dem wir
zusammen saßen und über diesen plan
nachgedacht haben
der erste film war nur ein experiment
ich hatte nie geplant die erika last zu
werden die ich heute bin
es war ein filmstudium abschlussprojekt
eigentlich die hat euer umfeld reagiert
als ihr ins pornogeschäft eingestiegen
sein
unsere freunde sind die gleiche
generation wie wir das war also
einfacher für die familie war es nicht
so einfach heute akzeptieren sie es weil
erika letztes jahr von der bbc zu einer
der einflussreichsten frauen gewählt
wurde und sie hat einen tatort gemacht
und bücher geschrieben und wird
respektiert und ich werde an
universitäten eingeladen um zu sprechen
ich denke dass sie deshalb gemerkt haben
dass das was wir machen nichts ekliges
an richtiges oder geschmackloses ist
sondern dass es sogar etwas wichtiges
ist
ich muss gestehen ich habe selbst all
diese vorteile und bin sehr überrascht
dass es so anders ist aber woher kommt
es dass wir alle diese vorgefassten
bilder über pornographie haben
ich glaube das liegt daran dass 90
prozent der pornografie sehr ähnlich ist
und wir machen etwas das immer noch
recht neues gab es aber nicht auch viele
hürden zu überwinden
es ist immer eine achterbahn
besonders weil unsere arbeit mit keiner
anderen industrie zu vergleichen ist es
gibt viele hürden und ängste seitens der
gesellschaft würdest du sagen dass ein
männlicher feminist ist hey leute ja ich
finde schon amt ab und zu werde ich noch
von meiner lehre
korrigiert aber ich habe natürlich viel
gelernt seitdem ich ärger kennengelernt
habe und jetzt haben wir zwei gemeinsame
töchter
was mich zum minderheit in einem haus
voller frauen macht also passt du dich
entweder an oder du gehst unter hier in
der bar paradiso im zentrum von
barcelona haben eric an pablo auch einen
film gedreht tödlich
[Musik]
die ba hat nämlich ein geheimnis hinter
einer wand attrappe toilette versteckt
sich ein weiteres zimmer
jetzt kenne ich den zugangscode
willkommen im geheimen zimmer
[Musik]
erika und pablo sind teil des sechs
positiven feminismus
dem gegenüber steht die sogenannte porno
bewegung die pornografie konsequent als
frauenfeindlich ablehnt aushängeschilder
sind zum beispiel die deutsche
aktivisten und verlegerin alice
schwarzer oder gilt 1 die in den usa
seit jahren gegen die sexistischen und
brutalen praktiken in der mainstream
pornografie kämpft frauen wieder
entstehen schnell im verdacht sechs
allgemein negativ zu sehen
zu unrecht sagt die nächste art und
weise wie frauen in pornos behandelt
werden kritisiert sie vor allem die
kommerzialisierung der lust vorne
kräftig ist die industrialisierung von 6
lassen sie es mich so sagen
pornografie ist für sex was mcdonald's
für essen ist da ist nichts falsches an
essen das ist ein normales wunderbares
menschliches erlebnis aber an mcdonald's
oder fast food industrie ist vieles
falsch wenn ich also sagen dass ich
gegen die pornoindustrie bin bin ich
nicht gegen sechs ich bin gegen die
pornoindustrie also die
lebensmittelindustrie kann reguliert
werden aber die pornoindustrie nicht man
kann sie auf viele arten regulieren und
wir müssen sie weg regulieren etwa mit
einer altersüberprüfung bei der jeder
nutzer von einer trifft person überprüft
wird bevor er auf porno websites
zugreifen kann
dann brauchen wir sammelklagen gegen die
porno produzenten wegen dem schaden den
sie darstellerinnen zugefügt haben die
vielen körperverletzungen und
vergewaltigungen
die meisten frauen werden auf dem porno
sind vergewaltigt auch wenn sie eine
einverständniserklärung unterschrieben
haben
und über das zivilgericht können wir die
porno produzenten so gut es geht
finanziell ruinieren
das ist der stärkste weg die pornografen
sind auf geld aus nicht sex erregt sie
sondern geld wir kriegen sie über ihre
bankkonten ganz anders als geld eins
sieht dass laura méritt auch sie findet
zwar dass da einiges im argen liegt im
sechs business allerdings begegnet sie
dem problem auf eine andere art in ihrer
heimat berlin betreibt sie den ältesten
sechs opfer frauen in europa dazu gehört
auch ein kleines museum
das ist jetzt also der älteste sexshop
europas ja das ist was ist von der
geschichte dahinter also von dem sex
schaut natürlich 30 jahre habe ich
dieses jahr eigentlich ja und klar vor
30 jahren gab es relativ wenig für
frauen und die sexspielzeuge waren alle
sehr einseitig mehr falle schlechtes
material riechende weichmacher und diese
ganzen sachen und hier das ist zum
beispiel ein ganz lustiges teil weil das
natürlich auch dazu diente die history
zu bekämpfen also wenn frauen halt als
historisch eingestuft wurden
dann wurde letztendlich eben auch ein
vibrator eingesetzt und das ist jetzt so
ist man das ist ein sehr sehr sehr
schweres teil
und da sollte dann sollte ja auch nicht
wirklich freude machen sondern es wird
dann halt irgendwie so bist du dann zu
diesem militärischen praxis muss kommst
und dann ist es erstmal auch wieder
vorbei dass das dann auch vermarktet
wurde ist ja natürlich auch eine
spannende sache also die bekämpfung der
weiblichen leiden die ja erstmal kreiert
wurden
die history und daneben haben sich die
frauen dadurch wieder beruhigt genau
aber es gab viele viele möglichkeiten
wie die history bekämpft wurde
du findest ja eigentlich das viel zu
wenig wissen über die sexualität da ist
was wissen wir denn nicht über die
weibliche und männliche sexualität
ich glaube tatsächlich dass wir schon in
der anatomie anfangen müssen also dass
viele gerade über die weibliche anatomie
einfach noch nicht im allgemeinwissen
angekommen ist kannst du uns mal die
wohl wir erklären hier ist das gerne
das ist die wundervolle wohl weiß es ein
kissen dass meine freundin elaine
gemacht hat weil sie festgestellt dass
es um mangelnde sexuelle aufklärung gibt
und hier hat sie halt ganz schön gemacht
dass wir hier ein auch mal die haube
sehen und hier drunter haben wir diese
wunderschöne quelle aber dass dann habe
darüber ist dass es äußere lippen gibt
es innere lippen
gibt das die natürlich sich öffnen
können
das wir hier sehen aha das ist die
übrigen stelle dann ist hier auch
wunderschön eingearbeitet die fläche und
überhaupt dass es so ein superschönes
innenleben ist und die auch manchmal
sachen jetzt ist aber genug und dann
macht sie die nimmt einfach mal wieder
zu
[Gelächter]
europas erste sexshop für frauen zu
gründen war laura méritt aber nicht
genug
seit 2009 führt sie außerdem alle zwei
jahre die feministische porno award
verleihen
paris in berlin durch sie ist also eine
absolute expertin in diesem bereich wann
ist ein porno feministisch also es gibt
keine feministischen pornos in dem sinne
wir haben kriterien
wir haben drei hauptkriterien das eine
wäre es einfach eine vielfalt an
sexualität dabei ist das heißt alle
männer aber auch frauen sollten dabei zu
sehen sein wie sie genießen wie
sexualität leben ja das zweite ist auch
vielfalt an körpern an hintergründen an
kulturen ein alter also all diese sachen
die wir eigentlich sonst eher als
kategorie als fetisch sehen das wollen
wir ihnen fühlen sehen und das dritte
ist ganz klar
fairness zum einen hinter der kamera
also dass da auch ein gutes team ist
aber das andere ist auch vor der kamera
das heißt ich möchte sehen wie die leute
miteinander in kontakt sind also den
konsens wie machen die dänen denn vor
der kamera war ich finde es sehen wie
kommunizieren die das sind die
hauptkriterien von feminismus nicht nur
von diesen anforderungen versucht auch
erika lust gerecht zu werden auf ihre
webseite wird klar ausgeschildert welche
kriterien für ihre pornos gelten
besonders wichtig die pro forma spell of
lights also die rechte und pflichten die
für ihre darstellen gelten die bill of
rights wird sowohl von der darstellenden
person als auch von ihr selbst
unterzeichnet
dennoch findet auch sie da laufen viele
dinge falsch in der pornobranche einige
davon lägen aber außerhalb ihre macht
was sich oft sehe ist dass die
produktion zwar korrekt durchgeführt
wurde
das filmmaterial dann aber in die
marketingabteilung kommt und dort
plötzlich nicht mehr ethisch korrekt
verarbeitet wird
zum beispiel werden junge
schauspielerinnen jünger vermarktet als
sie tatsächlich sind
sie waren offensichtlich voll wäre ich
als sie den film gedreht haben werden
dann aber als junger teenager vermarktet
wenn wir über ethische pornografie reden
müssen wir uns vor augen führen dass es
mehrere prozesse gibt die produktion die
vermarktung und distribution sowie die
konsumation es gibt viele menschen die
pornografie auf eine unethische art und
weise konsumieren indem sie auf die
kostenlosen web seiten
wir müssen daran denken wenn wir auf
diese weise pornografie konsumieren dann
geben wir unsere stimme für unethische
ausbeuterische produktionsbedingungen ab
ob umsonst oder für geld die nachfrage
nach pornografie ist gigantisch ganze 25
prozent aller suchanfragen im internet
sind pornografischer natur also jede
vierte suche die restlichen 75
beinhalten alles andere von
wissensfragen über gebrauchsanweisungen
bis hin zur suche nach jobs und
wohnungen
die drei größten porno website nix
videos helmste und porno erreichen
monatlich an der reichweite von 1,5
milliarden nutzern was viele nicht
wissen eine einzige firma kontrolliert
bei einem großteil der branche das
luxemburgische tech unternehmen meint
gibt was meint geht so mächtig macht und
von anderen anbietern unterscheidet sie
besitzen nicht nur die tube salz sondern
auch die agenturen welche werbungen auf
solchen kanälen schalten sowie viele
produktionsfirmen man spricht in der
branche von einem monopol welches für
den wettbewerb sehr schädlich sei und
zum beispiel die löhne der darstellenden
zugrunde gerichtet habe für alle filme
bezahlt werden weil sie ihre performance
anständig entlöhnen will weil sie so
sicher sein kann dass alle ihre
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer über 18
jahre alt sind so viele junge menschen
sind unmengen an online pornografie
ausgesetzt ohne die barriere dass dafür
bezahlt werden muss das ist ein problem
welches wir als gesellschaft diskutieren
müssen es hat schon unterschiedliche
lösungsansätze aus diversen ländern
gegeben
in großbritannien zum beispiel wurde
über eine mögliche alters identifikation
gesprochen
dieses daran gescheitert dass die
gleiche firma die auch die meisten
websites betreibt für die verarbeitung
der daten zuständig gewesen wäre und
diese firma hätte somit zugang zu vielen
privaten informationen gehabt
auch darauf welche pornos online
geschaut werden
es ist also recht schwierig ja sehr
erika lust ist mutter von zwei mädchen
wie leicht kinder zugang zu
pornografischen inhalten im internet
haben ist darum wie sie auch privat ein
großes thema von den zwölf bis 13
jährigen geben 18 an bereits pornos
gesehen zu haben bei den 14 bis 15
jährigen sind es 38 prozent und bei den
16 bis 17 jährigen die hälfte wie sehr
das thema mich als mutter beschäftigt
will rosander kreutzer von mir wissen am
liebsten verdrängt man das natürlich
aber machen wir uns nichts vor
also aufklärung oder das was sie über
sechs lernen wird mehrheitlich im
internet stattfinden und was sie da an
pornos sehen
sprichst du mit deinen kindern über
pornographie ja da hast du mich jetzt
ist ja irgend so ein thema das sieht man
immer ein bisschen raus und verdrängt es
auch meine kinder sind wirklich auch
noch sehr verspielt für ihr alter und
man hat das gefühl man ja gibt sie so
aus einer heilen welt raus aber
gleichzeitig haben die wirklich und
internetzugang sie lernen
medienkompetenz in der schule und die
werden früher oder später ganz sicher
auf pornos stoßen also macht es einfach
auch wichtig dass man es früher
thematisiert wir dürfen es nicht
unterschätzt welche tipps mir eine porno
produzenten wohl diesbezüglich geben
kann
als mutter von drei kindern erhoffe ich
mir rat von dir wie man mit kindern über
pornographie sprechen kann und wie man
sie darauf am besten vorbereitet das ist
ein ernstes und schwieriges thema ein
paar jahren haben wir das projekt in
polen konversation dot org gestartet
wir haben artikel und videos von
experten gesammelt und drei verschiedene
pdf leitfäden hochgeladen
nachdem wie alt ihr kind ist diese leute
werden erklären wie man diese gespräche
beginnen kann
ich glaube aber am wichtigsten ist das
bewusstsein dass man diesen gesprächen
nicht aus dem weg gehen kann
vor allem müssen wir unseren kindern
erklären dass pornografie nur für
erwachsene ist
sie müssen verstehen dass porno fiktiv
ist genauso wie superman fiktion ist es
gibt keinen menschen der wirklich liegen
kann
[Musik]
ein rat der auch für uns erwachsenen
gilt denn auch auf uns kann pornografie
negative auswirkungen haben wie negativ
wird allerdings häufig übertrieben
das findet auf alle fälle madita sie ist
kulturwissenschaftlerin und fokussiert
in ihrer forschung auf pornografie wir
wollen von ihr wissen warum die wirkung
von pornos an so umstrittenes thema ist
es gibt sehr viele mythen und um
pornografie es gibt sehr viel angst und
um pornografie und es gibt auch sehr
wenig differenzierte berichterstattung
darüber und am ende ist natürlich der
punkt wo breitere gesellschaft und die
erkenntnisse aus der forschung zusammen
kommen sind auch die medien und die sind
zum teil eben sehr undifferenziert und
sehr voreingenommen und das heißt da
sind oft sehr vereinfachte annahmen über
planung dafür im umlauf was sind so die
haare sträuben
also zum beispiel ein klassiker den man
immer wieder hört ist das porno
traktions störungen führt etwas was
gerade in letzter zeit sehr häufig durch
die medien gegangen ist man kann aber
nicht sagen dass das wissenschaftlich
bisher belegbar ist also was studien
herausgefunden haben sind nur
korrelation also dass ein zusammenhang
besteht aber keine kausalität
das ist natürlich auch ganz schwierig
nachzuweisen denn das würde ja bedeuten
dass man jeden faktor außer pornografie
ausschließen müsste im eigenen umfeld
und in der eigentlichen entwicklung und
eine andere große panik um pornografie
ist dass ausschließlich männer pornos
konsumieren also ich erlebe immer wieder
fassungslosigkeit wenn ich entweder von
hier spreche oder auch von anderen
frauen die pornos konsumieren also das
ist in unserer gesellschaft noch nicht
angekommen dass auch das realität ist es
ist zwar durchaus der fall dass das
publikum immer noch hauptsächlich aus
männern besteht aber eben nicht
ausschließlich
auch die sozialen medien haben ein
gespaltenes verhältnis zur pornografie
pablo dobler der mann von erika ist
verantwortlich für die verschiedenen
social media kanäle von lost productions
oft würden ihre inhalte zensiert oder
sogar gesperrt sagt er
zu unrecht denn im gegensatz zu anderen
seien ihre inhalte nicht sexistisch
ein gutes beispiel ist dieses
benutzerkonto von einem ex-soldaten der
marineinfanterie er hat 32 millionen
verlor und die art wie er seine
beziehung zu frauen und sexualität
darstellt ist perfekt für instagram für
ihn dreht sich alles um orgien mit
jungen frauen wie er seine hand zwischen
ihre beine legt oder wie er eine frau
als tisch nutzt um seine truppe hin zu
präsentieren oder um seine waffen ihm
gefallen frauen und waffen für uns ist
so etwas schwierig wenn wir nämlich die
beziehung zwischen frauen und männern
oder zwischen frauen und frauen auf
respektvolle schöne art zeigen werden
wir zensiert und nicht nur wir haben
dieses problem
das ist ein schönes beispiel dafür wie
instagram entscheidet was ihnen passt
und was nicht
dieses bild wurde zensiert danach haben
sie sich zwar entschuldigt aber es zeigt
trotzdem wunderbar die männliche
perspektive die scheinbar ist
hallo hier bin ich mit meinen mädels und
ich begrapschte ihre brüste oder wie
donald sagte ich begrüße ihre musik
solche sachen sind okay für diese firmen
aber all die anderen neuen ansätze nicht
dieses bild wurde ebenfalls zensiert
weil diese frau nicht rasiert sind ein
weiteres beispiel diese frau wurde
zensiert
aber wenn du sowas siehst dann ist es
kein problem das ist was heute passiert
es sind nicht viele leute die diese
entscheidungen treffen
es sind amerikanische unternehmen einige
wenige leute aus kalifornien
in kalifornien spricht über zensur was
tut ihr dagegen
wir können laut werden wir haben die
kampagne bei erst berning gestartet
worin wir alles zeigen was aus dem
internet entfernt wurde
wir wollen aufzeigen dass es eine
versteckte agenda gibt diese zensur
zeigt uns eine bestimmte vision vom
leben auf in europa und anderen teilen
der welt waren wir schon mal an diesem
punkt als wir sagten diese ethnie ist
gut und diese nicht
wir bewegen uns wieder in diese richtung
was wir machen können ist protestieren
denn um ihre plattformen führt kein weg
herum mit den sozialen medien steht
erika häufig auf kriegsfuß das geschäft
läuft aber gut immer mehr menschen
männer wie frauen konsumieren nämlich
ihre filme ganze sechs millionen umsatz
machtlos productions mittlerweile pro
jahr
du hast ein umsatz seiner firma
innerhalb von zwei jahren verdoppelt
ich denke dass wir zuschauer innen
angesprochen haben welche sich vorher
nicht so wohlgefühlt haben mit
pornografie wir sprechen besonders
frauen an indem wir ihre perspektive und
ihre erfahrungen in unseren pornos
berücksichtigen
ich habe aber auch gesehen wie sich cis
heterosexuelle männer verändern
ich bekomme ziemlich amüsante e mails in
denen sie mir schreiben
erika du hast pornografie für mich
zerstört
meine antwort ist dann was wieso habe
ich pornografie zerstört ich habe doch
nur mein bestes gegeben und dann
erklären sie mir weißt du ich habe
pornos online geschaut und war zufrieden
damit
ich habe gar nicht darüber nachgedacht
und dann lese ich einen artikel über
dich oder schaue deinen ted talk oder
ein interview und plötzlich realist
ihre ich dass ich das gar nicht will
wenn ich pornos auf diesen gratis
webseiten schaue und all diese tag lines
lese die so schrecklich über frauen
reden dann unterstütze ich diese werte
gar nicht das ging gar nicht ich solche
pornos will ich nicht mehr
ich habe gesehen wie menschen ein
bewusstsein entwickeln dass es ein
prozess ist und dass wir menschen fähig
sind uns zu verändern dass die
pornoindustrie oft sexistisch ist
darüber sind wir frauen in dieser
dokumentation mitwirken uns einig wir
konsumentinnen und konsumenten müssen
anfangen pornos bewusste zuschauen wenn
wir frauen verachtende darstellungen
konsumieren und nicht für pornografie
bezahlen fördern wir ausbeuterische
produktionsbedingungen aktivistinnen wie
g1 versuchen die branche haftbar zu
machen wenn zum beispiel körperliche
grenzen nicht respektiert werden und
sexuelle gewalt als selbstverständlich
dargestellt wird und produzentinnen wie
erika lust werden selber teil der
industrie und versuchen diese von innen
heraus zu verändern
als wirtschaftsjournalistin stimmt für
mich der letztere weg und dennoch bin
ich der meinung dass die
auseinandersetzung zwischen policen polo
wichtig ist denn nur wenn wir frauen
teil der debatte sind denn wir diese
auch mitgestalten
nur indem wir über porno sprechen finden
wir als gesellschaft den richtigen
umgang damit
[Musik]
sind pornos frauen ist eigentlich oder
passend pornokonsum und verließ zusammen
und kann mit pornografie dafür
gleichberechtigung kann was geht durch
den kopf teilt eure gedanken hier in den
kommentaren